[Music]
it's the cinematic event of the decade
and this is 31 details that you might
have missed in avengers endgame
now first up we won't be revealing what
happens in the end
who wins or loses if anyone dies or what
the plot the film is
instead we will be focusing on easter
eggs details things you might have
missed and
what the possible tie-ins are to
marvel's upcoming tv series on disney
plus
but we will be issuing a spoiler alert
because it reveals details that happen
in the film
right strap in because we have a lot to
get through
first up fans are hope that the classic
marvel post credits will contain some
call back to the schwammer scene
in the first avengers movie or something
that links to fantastic four
or x-men as disney purchased 20th
century fox and will retain the rights
to some of the characters
but there are no post-credit scenes in
endgame instead we're treated the marvel
hammer logo
with a single loud clink sound this
might be a direct call back to the sound
iron man makes when he first cast his
helmet all the way back in 2008's iron
man
this would be a fitting tribute to the
hammer strike that sparked 22 movies
over 11 years
or is it actually the sound of a bell to
tell all the characters that have been
lost
have a listen for yourself having right
six active producers on community
the russo brothers are no strangers to
having actors from the series pop up in
their films
look out for yvette nicole brown in lift
with a security badge
and kang jiang as a god of a lock-up
chain is also reading the book terminal
breach which has some parallels to the
mass loss of life in infinity war
the russo brothers love to slip in tv
and movie references
end game is no different a scene where
hawkeye runs from enemies as shown from
the trailers
appears to be a direct shout out to the
tunnel scene in aliens
also look out for shout outs to die hard
hot tub time machine
and the big lebowski listen out to a
reference for cheeseburgers in the movie
it's a reference to the iron man scene
where tony stark returns from captivity
only to immediately demand a
cheeseburger it's a fun nod to actual
events in robert downey junior's life
he claims the horror of eating a burger
king meal whilst on a drug fuel drive
snapped him out of his addiction and
sent him on a cleaner path
from the trailer we know that hawkeye is
mentoring his daughter at archery
almost in passing he refers to her as
hawkeye this will delight fans of the
female hawkeye kate bishop in the comics
will we be seeing a female hawkeye later
in the movie
hawkeye is involved in a street fight
you might recognize the actor he's up
against as japanese movie star hiroyuki
sonata
but thanks to the disney plus
announcement we know of several post
endgame spin-offs
one of these is with vulcan and winter
soldier in the movie
anthony mackie's character sam wilson
inherits cap's shield
we know from the comics sam becomes
captain america and that there have been
multiple caps over the years
so is it possible that he might appear
in this role in the upcoming series
speaking of disney plus we know that a
loki series is in the works as is one
with scarlet witch and vision
although it's unclear as to whether
these will be prequels or follow the
events of endgame
scarlet witch certainly gets her screen
typing end game and reminds us of how
powerful she really is
deserving of the solo series stanley's
cameo is
as good as we hoped in the 70s he's
driving a cart while shouting
make love not war both the number plate
on the car
and what he's saying have significance
here liberal-minded lee was assigned to
the army age
19 in world war ii but used his comic
book platform later in life to comment
on the vietnam war
student protests and political activism
in the film
we get to see peppa potts in the rescue
suit and in the comics tony builds this
suit for peppa
a photo of this was leaked last year so
fans were expecting pots to be battle
ready
at one point in the movie an all-female
lineup including peppa pot
nebula and okoye take on enemies this is
a direct reference to the series a force
with a lineup of she-hulk
dazzler and medusa it might be a
heavy-handed feminist moment but it
certainly reminds us all of the female
heroes in the mcu
the number a113 makes an appearance yet
again
in this movie disney fans will be
familiar with this number from nearly
every single pixar movie
it refers to a classroom number at the
california institute of the arts
speaking of numbers whilst leaving a
message for pepper in space at the film
start
tony says that it's been 21 no make it
22 days that they've been lost in space
endgame is the 22nd movie in the mcu
and numbers again when thanos has gone
to planet 0259-s
the avengers tried to find him the
number 259 might
refer to avengers volume 1 edition 259
which heavily features captain america
and nebula
in a pivotal scene in the movie black
widow has a callback line to budapest
from avengers you and i remember
budapest very differently
budapest is a thread that goes all the
way through the mcu with edwin jarvis
meeting anna there
even nick fury's backstory has him
retrieving cia information there with
escobar
and in the iron man 2 video game peppa
potts even makes a visitor
co-director joe russo has a cameo in the
group therapy scene in the film
joe has had cameos in all of the
avengers movies he's directed
even appearing dead in a tub in civil
war so look out for that
hail hydra this phrase is uttered by
captain america at one point
it's a shout out to the controversial
comic captain america steve rogers 1
where cap has a darker story arc which
fans have got hyped over
in a laboratory scene we also hear toby
jones voice off screen as the evil
arnhem zola
it's here that we get a glimpse of the
original ant-man comic helmet
lying on a table whilst being attended
to by hank pym
loads of marvel movies show a character
losing an arm now this is actually a
reference to the luke skywalker hand
chop
in star wars in this film nebula
corrupts her metal frame when she half
burns off her hand
near the end of the movie keep a lookout
for toy sim kins from iron man 3.
he's a kid tony is stranded with in rose
hill who snaps about with his anxiety
attack
and he makes a brief cameo in endgame
insider confirmed this
also look out for the gift that pepper
gives tony stark in iron man
proof that tony stark has a heart it was
used when tony collapses in his home and
needs a quick fix to his core being
compromised
watch out for the name morgan in
infinity war tony says morgan is the
name of an eccentric uncle that pepper
had
in the comics it's the name of a cousin
tony house who schemes against him to
try and take control of stark industries
it's the name of an important character
in endgame in the iron man movies we
repeatedly see tony stark on a rolling
stone cover that says
tony stark wants to save the world it's
a nice full circle moment then that he
contributes towards doing that in
endgame viewers might feel a little deja
vu when listening out for some of the
mcu's most quotable lines
the captain america line don't do
anything stupid until i get back
how can i you're taking all the stupid
with you makes a return
as does i could do this all day
there are also some location-specific
lines to look out for
cap revisits his conversation with
spider-man in civil war
saying hey queens what's up in the
earlier movie
kappa told peter that he was from
brooklyn also
tony refers to doctor strange as the
bleaker street magician
strange's sanctum sanctorum was on
bolica street in nyc
and they used bleecker street as a
nickname for him twice
we also get a mention of black widow's
dad's name this character's past has
been shrouded in secrecy but revealing
the name of her parents could lead to a
more fleshed-out backstory when her solo
movie arrives
one of the final scenes of the film are
lose to captain america's ability to
wield other weapons
there's a call back to the moment in age
of ultron where cap just manages to lift
thor's hammer mjolnir
it's the steve rogers we're familiar
with from the mighty thaw and fear
itself
and it proves a real treat for fans we
fittingly end on captain america's
backside
which fans went wild over in the end
game postage
the russo brothers are known fitting
memes and jokes into their movies
so the joke about captain america's part
being america's ass
will be a delight to some fans of course
there are tons more references that we
could have put into this list but
these are some of our favorites think
we've missed anything
comment below uh we fittingly end on
captain america's backside which films
talking about someone's thumb